are you a victim of a thot slap
is your wallet suffering from post-date
depression or
do you just not know how to react if a
thoughts being annoying
then look no further because today we've
decided to help our otaku brothers out
and give you a list that's
all about gender equality these top
thought slayers will be your guide
from simp to chad ps these situations
are all fictional okay so if you did
actually punch a woman in the womb
you would get arrested
we first begin with the supernatural
slayer psyche k
psyche has an extremely uncaring
personality with not so many interests
however he's very passionate about
sweets especially
coffee jelly psyche teleports to the
other half of the globe just to try that
new coffee
jelly place that opened up recently and
as such he's also willing to immediately
teleport to far away places upon
spotting an insect or a thought trying
to make a move on him
making teleportation a very important
skill to possess
sure psyche can punch a thot in the
teeth but that might kill her attracting
unwanted attention and annoyance
so instead he chooses to teleport to the
north pole avoiding
the mere interaction with a wild thought
okay so the next mad lad is mahiro
yasaka from hayure nyaruko san
and like psyki mahiro yasaka is just an
ordinary high school student
until one day he's suddenly attacked by
a dangerous monster
and just when everything seems to be
lost he's saved by a silver-headed girl
named nyaruko
who claims to be the shape-shifting
deity nyana thoughtep
from the horror author hp lovecraft's
cthulhu mythos
unlike the book version though this
nyanatho temp
is hella cute and highly effortable
and as luck would have it after rescuing
my hero from the alien
the lovecraftian deity falls madly in
love with my hero
and forces herself into his household
against his will
now usually our boy would avoid close
contact with nyaruko
and when it happens like the time she's
snuck to his bed like a body pillow
he just opens the window and throws that
thought away other than that he often
stabs the cute squid with a fork
[Music]
in there
foreign
from fork stabbing to reality check
punching in eighth place we have gamijo
from a certain magical index
now i know some of you would have
preferred accelerator instead and sure
he's killed lots of chicks
but they weren't of the thought nature
where on the other hand
gami joe's were gami joe has a power
called imagine breaker which negates all
magic
psychic or divine powers but also his
good luck
he tends to stay away from trouble but
possesses a strong sense of justice
which in turn is the cause of all of his
troubles after accepting the silverhead
lolly index in
a boy's life went to hell as a lot of
villains tried to kidnap her
from a crazed nun to a busty gypsy the
uppercuts them all back to reality
from the silver head lowly to the silver
head in toki
in seventh place it's sakata gintoki
taken
[Applause]
silver hair which he blames for his
lacking love life though
several female characters have shown an
interest in gentoki
he usually doesn't show any response and
merely puts up with them as annoyances
gintoki ladies and gentlemen is a weeb
with two major obsessions in life sweet
foods such as parfaits ice cream cakes
all that sort of stuff
and manga gintoki likes reading the
manga anthology magazine
weekly shonen jump and if any of the
so-called ladies try to come between
those things
they'll probably get poked in the eyes
right so now jodaro cujo is
up
[Music]
this jojo's bizarre adventure main man
is the definition of gender equality
every woman is to be treated like any
other street thug
hell he doesn't even have any issue with
using his stand to punch a thot back to
planet earth
hashtag friends of justice a main man
might be very tough and rather rough on
the outside
but he's also very dedicated intense and
loyal
he loves his mother and respects his
grandfather however he can be rude to
them
calling his mother an annoying bh
because he ain't no simp
not even for the woman who gave birth to
him no
[Music]
but in all seriousness it's not that
he's unaware of his love
he thinks anyone can tell his emotions
just by looking at him which in turn
doesn't help the adoring thirsty girls
constantly chasing his fashionably
outdated hats
[Music]
staying on the muscles note genzo from
kimono michi
is up genzo is the pro wrestler and
animal lover who took the anime world by
storm
after his infamous german suplex to the
blondie in the medieval dress
genzo became the face of so many videos
about thoughts layers
as a matter of fact if you search top
thought slayer moments
i think you'd easily find three videos
with a thumbnail from the show
and that's because there's no better
picture to showcase gender equality
than a masked wrestler delivering a
german suplex to a princess
nobody is safe from suplex city males
or females they're all gonna get it if
they mistreat the furry
nearing the top three now we have the
most savage harem mc ghazami yuji from
grisaia
why he's the most savage harem mc you
might ask well
when dealing with harem thots the dude
is as cold as an iceberg could be
for example he has no problem punching
an annoying red head in the face
after not seeing her for so long or
delivering some verbal attack without
stuttering in a word for a thought who's
acting up
yuji is no harem wuss if you're acting
like at sunderer
he'll call you on it and if he enters
the room while you're naked then he's
there to stay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the third slayer on the list is arkon
and the anime is aho girl
arkhan took an interest in brown-haired
yoshiko when he was a child
and has since then been trying to mend
her stupid ways but to no avail
no amount of verbal abuse and physical
punishment can keep yoshiko's iron jaw
down
chops jabs uppercuts double kicks
headbutts suplexes and giant swings are
all good methods to slay
however what truly got me isn't physical
punishment but the sheer disgust which
is displayed in the scene when yoshko is
sleeping half naked
like a 40 year old single man
[Music]
[Music]
aka the cautious hero is summoned from
another world by a useless goddess to
slay demons and beasts
which he does so well to the point that
thoughts start acting up
and when they act up he puts down seya's
slaying arsenal includes but isn't
limited to
pushing dodging slabbing kicking
and punching and if he's not feeding up
to the physical punishment
he can deliver some savage verbal shots
one of my favorite moments is that time
when a chick thought she could [ __ ]
slap him in front of everyone
friends of justice
[Music]
now i'd like to make it clear why gazuma
is number one over the rest
it's true that gazuma is not truly a
thought slayer but more of a gender
advocate
it's also true sometimes that he was
more of a simp
than slayer but hear me out godzilla
kind of started the whole thing as far
as i can remember
yeah start slaying as an ancient
practice handed down by jesus himself
but it's gazuma who through the ways of
the memes made it popular to call out a
thought
when she's acting too thotty and as such
i'd like to end on this clip
[Music]
who
and with these inspiring words we
finished the list
hope you enjoyed it and if you did then
as always like subscribe
comment and share with people who need
to see the way of true
gender equality that is all until next
time